عالمنا وهذه النقاشات التي ادت الى
تقويه الصله في التحالف اليوم
متحدثين السابقين الرئيسي
والمستشارز تحدثنا عن الوضع الخطير
وقد مر على الحرب الكارثيه التي بدات
روسيا في اوكرانيا وحتى بان
الوقت للاستنتاجات لم يحن بعد لكننا على
دراغون باننا يجب ان نركز على هذه الحرب
وعلينا ان لا ننسى في الوقت ذاته ان هناك
حروب اخرى في الشرق الاوسط في منطقه
القوقاز
وحروب ضد الارهاب
وما سالت القضايا النوويه مهمه جدا
لكننا اليوم
اوكرانيا هي جوهر الموضوع
بعد عام
وبعد النتائج كبيره
ان اسلط على نقطه مهمه اليوم هذه الحرب
ليست حرب في اوروبا بل تعني العالم باكمله
فما من مبرر على الاطلاق لهذا العدوان
وقلت هذا قبل اشهر عندما تحدثت في الامم
المتحده
وقلت ان هذا سلوك الامبريالي جديد نراه
عبر هذا العدوان على دوله جوار
وبالتالي هذا فيه عدم احترام للاراضي
والسياده
هناك قانون وحقوق لابد من
تحقيقها
فمساله
الامبرياليه
شرعيه في العالم وكل القواعد
انتهكت ليس فقط ميثاق الامم المتحده
بل
الدول الاعضاء
في مجلس الامن
وكان هناك
تدمير لبنى تحتيه مدنيه
وارتكبت الجرائم ضد السكان
المدنيين والعمل الذي قام به
سيد رشيد
للطاقه ذريه كان مهم جدا
وقد كان عظيم مع ايران ويجب ان لا نقلل من
شان ذلك هناك طابعات وروسيا هي الوحيده
المسؤوله عن هذه الازمه ازمه وفره الغذاء
على الرغم من الاجراءات التي اتخذناها
كلنا لصالح الدول التي تتطلب حمايتنا
من يعتقدون ان هذه مساله اوروبيه اقول لهم
ان هناك معتدل واحد
ودوله استهدفت وهذا امر واضح وعلينا
ان لا نشكك في ذلك ولا نريد
زعزعه الاستقرار
دون ان نتدخل في هذا الشان الامر الثاني
هو
العدوان الروسي كان قد
تكلم
باربعه هزائم اولها في ساحه المعركه
وكانوا يعتقدون ان الحرب ستكون سريعه وان
اوكرانيا لن تستطيع المقاومه وانها خلال
اسابيع ولكن
الشجاعه الكبيره للقوات الاوكرانيه والشعب
الاوكراني والقياده الاوكرانيه
وكل من هم معنا اليوم بمن فيهم
الرئيس الذي شاهدناه عبر الشاشه كلهم ابدو
هذه
شجاعه اوقفوا هذه الخطه
وبالتالي راينا ما حدث في خرسان وكل هذا
هزيمه
للخطه العسكريه الروسيه الهزيمه الثانيه
هي هزيمه
في الاستعماريه
فالفكره كانت هي خلق حالات ايرباك
ومناطق نفوذ
وكان هناك شرعيه لهذه الحرب لكن هذا لم
ينجح حتى بعد عام
المساله هي لتوضيح ان روسيا هي قوه
تحقق
عدم توازن وعدم تكافؤ
بقوات هذه وقد شهدنا ذلك عبر السنوات
الاخيره
شاهدنا كيف
استمرت روسيا
عندما قالوا
ليسوا ملكه هو هذه القوات وهذه المجموعه
هي
اصبحت قوه
رسميه ويستخدمونها
وكانها اداه مافيا جديده
والهزيمه
الثالثه هي هزيمه النظر الى المستقبل
لان
النتيجه هي عباره عن
اوكرانيا وقواتها بقرار
السويد وفنلندا بالانضمام لنيتو وهو ان
اطلع الجميع ماذا دعمنا من خلال مندوب
الدول الحاضره نحن بحاجه لمزيد من التعاون
الدولي وهناك عدم ثقه تجاه روسيا
واصبح الدفاع عن النفس مهم جدا وفي منطقه
القوقاز كيف يمكن حل الوضع هناك بروسيا
القوه الاستعماريه الجديده
وقد طماني الرئيس
[موسيقى]
الهزيمه
لا تقلقني بل
بوتين يعطي روسيا مكانه عالميه وكيف تكون
مصدره للمواد الخام وليس
امه مهمه في العالم فكيف يمكن ان تكون قوه
متوسطه الحجم هذا يسبب عدم الثقه من كل
الدول وهذا هو الوضع الحالي قبل عامين
شاركتكم هذا الراي لا احد يغير
جغرافيه روسيا ولا احد هنا في
يمكن ان يغير هذه الجغرافيه او هذه
المعضله بانه ما من سلام دائم في المنطقه
ما لم تحلل القضيه الروسيه بالشكل معقول
ودون
التعاون لابد ان نتشارك في هذه المساله
وبالتالي كنت اؤكد مرارا وتكرارا منذ بدء
هذه هذا صراخ كنا في حاله نبين
الوحده
ونسعى للحوار كذلك كلما امكن ذلك
والان ساعه الحوار لم تحن بعد لان روسيا
تبدي
الرغبه في الحرب وتكثيفها وقررت
ان
تستهدف البنى التحتيه المدنيه وان ترتكب
جرائم حرب
روسيا يجب ان لا تفوز بهذه الحرب ولا
تستطيع ذلك وهجماتها يجب ان تفشل
يجب ان لا نسمح
اللجوء للعنف ان يصبح امر طبيعي
لان هذا يشكك بالاستقرار في العالم او
يزعزع الاستقرار في العالم
وقد شاهدنا منذ بدء صراع
هناك
اجراءات لاجل
الامن فقط فرضنا من عقوبات على روسيا
ووفرنا دعم
انساني وعسكري لاوكرانيا وللشعب الاوكراني
وحمينا البنى التحتيه المدنيه في اوكرانيا
وقدمنا الوسائل الماديه واود ان اشكر
الامين العام على كل ما قام به وفي كل مره
تسعى فيها
فرنسا لاضافه قيمه لما تقدمه
لاوكرانيا بارسال الدفاعات
وحمايه
الاوكران وكذلك رومانيا واستونيا نحن
نساعد في تقويه
دفاعات
الشرقي
كما شاهدنا
مجموعات القوات البحريه قد تعاونت وكان
هناك دوما مساله اذا كان هذا الصراع سيصل
الى الاراضي الرماديه لكن مرارا وتكرارا
عملنا
تجاه الاتفاق وهنا
اتحدث عن تكثيف جهودنا
لمساعده الشعب الاوكراني كي تتمكن
اوكرانيا
من اطلاق
ارتفاعاتها وتحت
وضع الراهن فقط اختارت ان تكون في هذا
الموقع ونحن مستعدين لان نكثف جهودنا على
مدى الاشهر
والاسابيع القادمه وكذلك مستعدين للمحافظه
على ان نبقى اقوياء طوال مده الصراع لكن
علينا ان نبقى ذوي مصداقيه
في مثابرتنا وهذا ما تريد ان تسلط عليه
فرنسا الضوء هذا اليوم
الوحده
والعزيمه مهمه جدا لتوفير الوسائل للعوده
الى مائده التفاوض بشكل مقبول
والعمل على سلام طويل الامد حسب الشروط
التي يضعها الاوكرانيين وفي هذا الوقت
ادعو
اصدقائنا الاوروبيين اليوم
ووفقا للمبادئ التي اتلتكم عليها دعاء
اول دعوه الاولى هي
اننا لتحقيق السلام بحاجه لادوات فرنسا في
هذا الاطار تضع
كل جهودها وكلما واجهنا
اي مازق استراتيجي نتعاون معا ونقدم عدد
او مبالغ ماليه
لدعم تلك الجهود لكن اعاده تسليح يعني
ان نعزز
القاعده الدفاعيه والتكنولوجيه في اوروبا
وهناك مبادئ لابد ان نواصل العمل عليها
والاوكرانيه لابد ان تواصل على ذلك المسار
بما فيها الدعم الصناعي من اوروبا
وهذا بحاجه
لتسليح وان يتناسب ذلك مع اوروبا
والقدره
لابد من زيادتها في اوروبا
ونحن بحاجه لبرنامج للدفاع في اوروبا
كي نتمكن من
الاستفاده من صندوق
الدفاع الاوروبي ربما نفكر بتغيير وتيره
العمل
وقطاع
الصناعات الحربيه التي تسعى لتقويتها هو
بحاجه الى مزيد من التقدم والتبسيط على
المستوى
الاوروبي ومناشده الثانيه هي
علينا ان نفكر بالجانب النووي من هذه
المساله
القضايا
النوويه
مهمه
ونحن بحاجه لحمايه حلفائنا في هذا الاطار
علينا ان نسال نفسنا ما هو دور سلاح
النووي وما هو
افضل السبل للرضا
وذلك من اجل
حمايه هذا التحالب
ان نكون مره ثانيه قادرين على تاكيد
الجانب النووي
ونفكر بمعنى ذلك واود ان اقرر
اكرر ما قلته سابقا
ان لدي ان علينا ان نعزز الردى النووي
د كذلك
ثالثا ان ادعو الجميع لاعاده النظر
باساليبنا الابنيه فاوروبا
في مساله
الحد من التسلح
اعتقد انها يجب ان تعيد النظر في هذه
السياسات
صواريخ متوسطه المدى
وهذه الاسلحه مهمه والولايات المتحده
قررت
التسعى لعقد اتفاقات حول ذلك
وبالتالي نحن لم نشارك في كثير من
الاتفاقات حول هذه الاسلحه ونحن عملنا
وكاننا اقليه
اوروبيه وبالتالي لابد ان نشارك في مثل
هذه المسائل الامنيه وان نضمنها معا مع
شركائنا في الناتو وكذلك كاروبيين
المعاهده ناقشت
نقشت على مدى سنوات الماضيه ولم ندعى
اليها وبالتالي لا يوجد معاهده
وعلينا ان نتخذ استنتاجاتنا من هذه
المساله
وبالتالي
التموضع الاوروبيه الدفاعي مهم
وكان لدينا
كمعاهده الايناف التي لم تعد موجوده
مساله الدفاعات الجويه في القاره
الاوروبيه اعتقد
كما اشاره الرئيس تشارلز نحن نشارك في هذه
الجهود لابد ان يكون لدينا مؤتمر حول
الدفاع الجوي في اوروبا لابد ان نخصص
مؤتمر لذلك
بدعوه كل من يقدمه حلول الامنيه
ومن ناحيه استراتيجيه لابد ان نناقش هذه
المسائل من الجانب الاستراتيجي وفي الوقت
ذاته الردى
وهذه مسائل لابد
ناخذها بالاعتبار اوروبا
مهتمه
بنظام امني عالمي جديد
والاليات التي يمكن ان توقف اي دوره
عنف او اعتداءات
مبادئ لحمايه الحدود
والدول وسياده الدول
ولابد ان نؤكد على هذه المسائل وان يكون
لدينا هيكليه ذات مصداقيه
والحد من التسلح وناهيك عن مساله وجود
اطار يمنع الازمات ازمات طويله الامد في
هذه القاره
يمكن ان نستخدم هيكليات قائمه مثل اتفاقيه
التعاون الاقتصادي ولا اتحدث هنا من
ناحيه
مفهوميه
الاتحاد الاوروبي موجود لكننا بحاجه
لمجتمع اوروبي لابد ان يكون له دور خاص
بعض الشركاء قرروا
الخروج من الاتحاد الاوروبي لكنهم
بالمجتمع الاوروبي السياسي وهم شركائنا في
الطاقه والامن يشاركون كثير من القضايا
وهناك دول اخرى
تودع الانضمام اليهم ونامل ان يتم ذلك قد
يكون بعيدين عن ذلك اعتقد ان
النرويج وبريطانيا مولدوفا واوكرانيا
هذا مجتمع سياسي اوروبي لديه فرصه
للحيلوله دون مثل هذه الازمات وايجاد
هيكليه
كما اشرت قبل قليل
ونحن نبدي لرئيس مولدوفا دعمنا
نحن بحاجه لمزيد من التعاون في قاراتنا
والنيتو له دور اساسي في هذه المساله
والاشهر الاخيره بينت ان من يؤمنون
بمن بان النيتو هو
بضم دول ليس تهديد بل يعزز هذا التحالف
وهذا منطقي
وقد ابدينا
اصرارنا لتحقيق
اهدافنا الاستراتيجيه ولدي ايضا مناشدتين